bonjour nous sommes actuellement volts
mcdonald's mais aussi le vendeur au port
qui se confond dans un aéroport
aujourd'hui on va aller en colombie
qu'est-ce qu'on va [ __ ] en colombie on
va faire une petite surprise à mon frère
il est en amérique du sud depuis un an
près de huit mois
il fait un méga route de la mort là-bas
chose que je n'aurai absolument jamais
les couilles de faire il est parti avec
sa copine aujourd'hui on est le 9 août
et il fête ses 26 ans le 12 août
ça fait huit mois qu'ils parlent tous
les soirs à sa copine de moi il disputa
le cas je laime le manque c'est faux
donc avec la collaboration de sa copine
on lui a préparé cette petite surprise
je vais le rejoindre sur qu il ne se
doute de rien vu que je m'ennuie je
décide d'aller sur les parisiens se
passer le temps et sur quoi je tourne
mon premier article
le vol mh3 eux disent approuver dans
l'océan
c'est michael
un gros fail je vais arriver mon frère
n'est pas là quel est mon frère vient de
passer devant moi on va les chercher en
scred
comment ça va ça va quoi à se retrouver
et à ça près moi j'ai tout y était la
bac a manqué de tranchant
demain on va prendre un bus pour aller
où c'est parfait à des bas-fonds au
charme à demain ici il est le matin il
est actuellement 11 heures et je remette
une vidéo en ligne je vous présente
notre chambre
c'est une chambre 5 étoiles et ça
parfois je vois électrique de ma vie
loli immense nouvelles ont reculé
what are we going to do to lay le bus ou
le taxi le but sur le taxi opium de ce
bras et on va à salt et rod fanni
théophile is a waterfall celtes et
robuste taureau
combien de vivre ça prend trois heures
et il nous reste une heure avant
d'arriver à cette rousse est un honneur
nous venons d'arriver à salem toronto
après quatre heures de bus
c'est une petite ville entre des
montagnes russes avaient repéré un
hostel donc on va aller voir à la
semaine passée un peu plus gai tout est
ok hostel repérer
donc là elles m'ont élu prix le gars à
10 50 euros par nuit par personne puis
ça vous à cannes et on a finalement
trouvé un échantillon du dortoir
familiale dans quel s arrêta avec
attention une salle de bains séparés il
ya eu des indications à suivre aussi
lancé dans ce projet bon on ne
s'implique pas ce qu'on me vois pas ne
fume pas de plan ne fait pas de course
et j'ai qu'ils aient besoin de préciser
surtout n'oubliez pas s'il vous plaît
dans ses murs nous sommes sur le ou les
auteurs
bon du coup on est bien six heures que
j'ai c'est pour copier je libèrent
l'odeur
[Musique]
donc là étaient contents qu'ils veulent
dans qui annotel dix fois mieux à lui m
avec un max de vitre dont beaucoup de
lumière dans une petite sieste on a
regardé un match de basket à politique
là on va le restaurant il ya une meuf
qui chante sais pas d'où ça vient c'est
incroyable vous arrêter vous voit deux
enfants bande de gamins et ça ça
septembre puisque moi cet homme à 26 ans
12 août le luxe qui n'est pas avec 24
heures mon gars c'est une [ __ ] de bon
c'est dans les dentifrices parce que
c'est sale et on trippe cette aventure
seront tous brosser la saleté ses
intérieurs de dormir benoît la
population voilà ça c'était un autre
regret ce matin aujourd'hui on va tester
un parc très clairement aux égyptiens
sur le parc
plus sur la piste on voit aussi arriver
c'est extrêmement bon que l'amertume de
taille partout autour de nous et pour
faire un article vous acheter un chapeau
et un punch offert quelques jours pour
être comme les gens disent la pression
du shom santos winchester faire du rodéo
donc elle a en fait c'est une sorte de
randonnées à travers ses plus hautes
montagnes et quelque part et un parc
avec des colibris et on veut les voir
est ce qu'une petite foulure de chevilly
entre ces deux cailloux est vite arrivé
mais bien ses chaussures qui échoit dans
un premier temps le même au cas dans la
charte il voyagera beaucoup de trucs est
haut comme ça ça fait maintenant trente
minutes qu'on marche
et bonne nouvelle un panneau qui indique
qu'à zadelhoff collet bis on y va bon
mon frère vous devez alors le génie en
action jeunesse
un papa papa tu penses que la fibre ici
je me ferais bien un petit au maroc il
ya deux possibilités soit on prend le
pont là bas comme absolument sans
consent des gens sont faits les méthodes
la vie ghetto du de la stricte et on
prend ce chemin là c'est la table la
petite a connu ses parents [ __ ] de
castor
[Musique]
si les amis après 1h30 de marche au
total nous sommes arrivés on aperçoit
des cabanes ah bah voilà on aperçoit un
abonné ils ont peur d'avoir des
peut-être pas content avec le chèque on
est vraiment collé à ou quoi évidemment
à côté c'est incroyable adeline photo
pool d'artistes ouais tu sais un artiste
moi j'ai une grosse merde je pose la
gopro chérien c'est vraiment les oiseaux
hyper vifs envers des petites méduses et
un colibri qui entend se noyer pas de
rythme et à rigoler quand même pas un
petit café ce matin on leur dit allez on
va retracer des rivières en mode man vs
wild
ok on est sur le retour et on a croisé
un groupe de cheval et en fait on peut
redescendre en cheval et mon frère ça le
fait qu'il fait il est juste déçu de pas
avoir eu un petit chapeau de cow boy
dans la foulée c'est rigolo
chalabi
[Musique]
s'amuse la non l'istiqlal qu il va
défoncer voilà on vient d'arriver
on a tous déjà explosé de saison trotter
comme les bâtards petit coup c'est sa
manière de dire en moi
[Musique]
labonal un cheval est terminée et nous
sommes devenus des comptes maire de la
commune petit chapeau
petit coup de chaud franchement on
ressemble presque aujourd'hui ok après
ce petit café
on a mis nos bonnes choses sur nous on
est vraiment des vrais colombien et on
va aller en haut de sa marche
apparemment il ya une superbe vue sur la
ville auquel vient d'arriver en haut et
regarder cette vue c'est super joli
c'est de toute beauté à l'origine
bizarre au début ce fut bref mais
intense comme ma première fois atteint
jeudi cela est mon frère dit c'est faux
et il insiste vraiment on dirait car on
a parfois j'ai fait avec lui c'est une
période qui te rends compte l'atypique
d'ici s'appelle le compte des français y
sont plaints klaunzer e avocat l'eau
viennent sauf si ce ping viol corps paix
avec moi merci chers fans je suis un sac
de couchage sur mon matelas
je suis la nuit il fait très froid ici
minérale devoir de prendre un bus
direction de medellin viendra pour cette
heure là barreau médine c'est cool bonne
nuit tout le monde
[Musique]
les amines sommes dans le bus est en
fait c'est totalement un bus luxueux il
ya même des écrans sur les sièges risque
équipe est rarissime et super content on
va dormir pendant six heures nous venons
d'arriver
on a fait nos moeurs de bus à huit
heures de bus au lieu des 6 heures de
près mon seul regret de ses voyages
c'est que peu importe situation j'ai
toujours un short quechua sortir henri
chartier choix randonnée chantée choix
pour se poser pour boire un café et j'ai
cru que des fourmis transporter la
nourriture
en fait c'est un insecte quel est cet
insecte improbable si quelqu'un a déjà
vu ça apparemment quand on tue il
explique aux problèmes les normes
sismiques a déjà eu autant envie que
j'entends palais ne j'avance le seul
marchand le soir et nous allons aller
fêter les personnes de cet homme dans un
bar donc avant la danser la salsa au
barça
on à l'ambiance était au sommet dans ses
bras on aurait pu parler personne danser
et à presque genre qu'ils achètent tout
savoir ici et vont se poser sur les
marges at elle affronta n'ai voulu
tourner des moutons au bercail
c'est très très stylé où il ya de la
place il ya des gens pour la gym à base
de salto de flip
son style est beau et musclé c'est à
dire tout ce que je te tue
qu'est ce qu'il se passe et personne
sait comment je voulais c'est simple
bois et du quiz arrête les acrobaties
sera billets sont en train de partir tu
fais dans les mentions monsieur dans un
bar et percutant prestige et plus de la
marche athlétique
[Musique]
on met de fait beaucoup avec mon crâne
fait qu'on est petit on s'amuse à faire
des constats marché permettra peut-être
à leurs embryons se moque d'eux mais ils
vont plus vite que nos grands sprints
j'espère qu'ils sont dans ces pokémon ou
dans la poche
si vous passez lui consacre uniquement
pour leur zone et la cote ces derniers
n'ont pas les couilles toutes les audi
km et claude gladu réflexe à lui la
classe c'est trop bien dans ma peau est
[Musique]
on allé se coucher on a eu cette journée
sur sa paye plus d'échecs au lieu dit sg
la paix il veut pas aller fleurantins
gros gars sont tous à nous demander
bewkes d'emmener le navire peut faire ça
[ __ ] mais c'est pas possible qu'on
arrête de faire l'effort
et ce mec il a six ans de plus que moi
[ __ ] je rends va te laver les pieds
les gens tu veux dire on fait la mêlée
qui font ce qu'elles permettent de
trouver des alternatives s est un enfant
élevé du produit à moustiques ses pieds
en pensant que l'odeur à partie ce bon
sur cela pour bien dormir je vous ai
vraiment hâte le mans
[Musique]
il est 16 heures 50 et cette journée
commence seulement pour nous pour
avancer un peu molle aujourd'hui on a un
petit tour dans la ville et surtout
aujourd'hui il est l'heure de se faire
tatouer
on a décidé que mon frère de se faire le
même bien de tatouage lui se fera dans
deux semaines parce que après il
continue son voyage et pourra pas se
baigner ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui
wells a tatoué un animal c'est un animal
impressionnant est une belle chose
incroyable et je raconterai après
pourquoi on a fait ça
l'histoire qui vient derrière à
l'histoire est aussi importante que
l'animal ce mot somme ou tatouage était
venu une première fois ce matin pour me
dire qu'est ce que vous voulez je vais
dire ce n'est dans 4h voyage en décembre
des saoudiens on est revenu on a vu le
dessin c'est génial hélène lefranc dans
le quinze minutes durant et à toi j'ai
ma vie me rase du coup j'ai un bon bras
vraiment ridicule c'est tout doux c'est
bon je suis un peu en fait je peux
mentir non pas parce que j'avais un truc
que je connais sur la peau ce que j'ai
dit ça c'est le monsieur qui veut tout
en offrant des sensations ça va faire
mal
le tatouage est terminée après deux
heures de séance intensive
si vous êtes prêts à voir ce que c'est
voilà un crabe avec un chapeau fait le
député confrères ont dormi face à face
et nos pièces touchés et on s'amusait à
chauffer le pied de l'autre en refermant
ce boîtier comme des pinces de crabe et
on disait que tu lui du j'ai une pince
de crabe ballast et 15 on était content
de retour à l'hôtel hostel qu'on a
sélectionné pour une seule raison il
était indiqué qu'ils possèdent une ps3
les coups on va faire un film à 14 jours
est à c'est un petit tir est ce qu'on
appelle finalement deux lucarnes
quelle est ta réaction que leur chat
alors terrena est un bijou il joue je ne
veux même pas plus que pour le jour
[Musique]
mais non c'est une victoire 3-0 on
faisait ça creuse
[Musique]
surprise je suis de retour à paris voilà
j'avais pas filmer ces derniers jours
puisque déjà été ramassés spécial que
j'ai envie de profiter un max avec mon
frère avant de rentrer oui j'ai chopé
une rhinopharyngite la dernière nuit est
ce qu'on est content non je n'explose
est il acceptable ça qui rôdent autour
de ma valise quechua on va pas se mentir
c'est mon pack un sac
c'est mon top 5 bah écoutez je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi ce petit voyage
avec moi c'est cool j'espère que vous en
avez qui fait même si je vous ai montré
en vrai petit pourtant du truc c'est
toujours bien de richesse vers m sur
source est un peu de vivre des choses et
de revenir plus frais à saïx f les
caresses d'un coup un je vous remercie
encore d'avoir gardé que je vous dis à
très notre prochaine vidéo c'était les
vacances au colombie et la surprise aux
frères jazz band baisse
[Musique]